Russian army in their tanks they were
mere two Fields ahead this is where they
were hiding that is what life in the
trenches looks like if people are
wondering what happens to those pickups
provided by volunteers here's a great
example this one got a direct pit were
they applying some electronic warfare
why didn't you know how many of them
there were they had it all they still
have loads of things even the abandoned
equipment demonstrates to us how severe
the battles were here take a souvenir
you can keep it
I doubt you could film anything like
this
we recaptured this small area it now
looks so insignificant on a global scale
and yet it will become the last drop in
the bucket that would help us take back
here son
this one here for example it's an Odessa
patch it belongs to a guy who
participated in an assault on the
pumping station he's one of many this
guy used to be one of the ultra's
football fans from Odessa those very
guys who used to shout football in the
streets are now among the best of all
fighters a Bob Marley unit oh yeah it
belongs to majahid this is another patch
from him somewhere here this one is from
the 72nd Brigade you see each one of
these patches has its own story this is
how the 59th brigades patch used to look
like but now it looks different that is
how it looks
um
it went through some decommunization
yeah a little bit but now I'm not sure I
understand what it is is it a road
people say as if someone counted that
there are 59 Corners here these ones are
Russian you see this one is still
stained with blood we wash the patch but
didn't manage to wash away the blood
this one is in Russian as well this is
the Russian corner you know some kernel
hitches a ride sees all this and wonders
wow what a cool collection let me give
you this one dispatch here is from The
Comeback alive charity Foundation bit by
bit The Collection grows you know this
one is from the bond charity our Beauty
a Founder she's a star she provides a
lot of help to our military we'll drive
through a lot of [__] now he owe me a
car wash deal
so what the heck
we can only drive on the road here
there are mines still around here right
yeah this place is littered with mines
unexploded shells and so on you don't
want to risk it by driving on the grass
you know what I'm talking about one has
to be careful
Crusher
yeah you know it's better to play it
safe
this is the very road we were using all
the time I took part in just three
attempts to take over the pumping
station
but the other guys were going there much
more often
so the fighting here was quite difficult
as this area is just an open field right
in general here the atmosphere was quite
special
for example when I when I was first
fighting this
what's it called
um
in the next Direction they were cool
spoil tips there were forests Glades you
can see and now look around at this
place you can imagine how it was to
advance here when for example the
Russian ambassadors were hiding in the
trees and in order to reach them you had
to cross the open field the step
exciting isn't it was anything growing
in this field
there was wheat
no it was it was burned down completely
I remember what a Pity it was to watch
the Harvest just just going down the
drain
did farmers make any attempts to rescue
the Harvest
yeah well they did and they rescued some
it was such a bizarre scene to watch the
artillery duels between the ukrainians
and the Russians raging and a combine
harvester Gathering crops in the midst
of it all
those farmers who were driving those
Harvesters deserve the status of
military operations participants you
know
medals for bravery and all that
many people stayed they work and they
help the Army and many of the farmers
were just not helping they fought as
well
all those memes with tractors did not
come out of nowhere
yeah yeah that's right that's right
memes about tractor brigades stealing
tanks that's them stealing tanks all
right
we're going to the pumping station now
this one was one of the key points where
the liberation of her son started from
well at least for me every direction has
its key point and for us for example for
the 59th Brigade this pumping station
was a bone in the throat and as soon as
we broke through to the pumping station
the things were snowballing before that
we were just defending and then the
first attacks began and the first let's
say successful operation when we took
over the pumping station after that we
recaptured another small piece of
Woodland with no name and so we started
to advance step by step to hit Sun
I've mentioned this recently and I'll
say it again here
hereson and donats regions and up north
at the border with Belarus each of us
defend their own home place no matter
how far it is from the front line
here I defend my hometown
the others defend cave in your
views
so that's how we were driving over these
holes and bloody craters every single
day under the fire this was always
happening Under Fire there were constant
explosions on both sides of the roads
and the road itself was fully exposed to
the enemy fire
thank you
foreign
[Music]
actually started from
about 50 kilometers
but there was almost no fighting near
kirison itself all the battles were
actually fought along this line
it was roughly midway between Nikolai
and Carson the fights were taking place
mostly in the middle of the area between
mikolai and kirison
this was one of the strong points of the
59th Brigade it's a settlement but you
can see how it looks now it's simply
leveled with the ground
there may not be even a single attack
building the whole village is completely
destroyed
foreign
the Russian army in their tanks they
were a mere two Fields ahead what did
they use everything they could they used
everything these are not some ditches
they were made for vehicles protection
and this here is a shelled vehicle
Russian Artillery hit the vehicles if
people are wondering what happens to the
pickups provided by volunteers here's a
great example this was a direct hit
but I think this was either a Mitsubishi
L200 or a Nissan it was directly hit
that's what military vehicles look like
after they're hit
it doesn't seem to be burnt out
completely was the fire extinguished
honestly I don't remember how it was
there was such a firestorm here that
foreign
there was the arrival of 152 caliber
rounds
[Music]
all right
be careful it's slippery here
well this is where we were hiding from
the enemy fire you can use your
flashlight to walk in those tunnels
thank you
this is what a life in trenches looks
like
foreign
This was um one of the companies of the
11th battalion
this house even looks not so damaged
you can see the traces of shrapnel
everywhere every dot could mean a death
to somebody thank God it hit the house
and not a person
that's a terrible thing
see how big the explosions were here
what caliber it was
[Music]
not a single house remained intact here
as you can see in fact the village is
deoccupied but it's dead there's no
sense in staying here especially with
winter coming there will be nothing to
do here in the winter The Village may
come to life again one day but neither
the land nor these houses is worth
anything at the moment
there were no people here at all just
animals cows pigs geese and hens were
running around everywhere there was
plenty of food running around and they
were dying all the time here's an
example a cow was wandering the area and
a round exploded the cow fell so you
could have some fresh meat that's awful
there were so many animals falling dead
dad as far as I know local authorities
and the commander of the 59th Brigade
started to catch those cows and take
them take them elsewhere just you look
at this that's exactly how it was
what a fat pig or is it just pregnant
yeah it could be pregnant this is a
Vietnamese potbelly pig or similar it
seems so
and right here some really big pigs were
wandering around so you knew you'd have
at least some food and also volunteers
would bring us everything so you know
there was plenty of food
that was rather an unusual experience
it's so warm outside so wonderful it
feels great huh I hear some helicopters
flying by I wonder if they're ours or
not but anyway the entire assault action
began from this tree line we disembarked
the carriers and started our Advance
through those trees towards the pumping
station there was some Greenery at that
time and there were a few trenches here
and there
our Advance would stop to a halt as soon
as their artillery started shooting at
us rather aggressively we could not just
stand up and go ahead as there was a
real Firestorm all around you could see
all these trees are chopped down by the
artillery fire
they're all damaged not a single one of
those trees was left intact and so it
kept moving through those trees towards
the pumping station
some would die mainly from the artillery
shelling
um at first you know Firearms they were
they were rarely used
but as the fight reached its Tipping
Point it all turned into a firearm
shootout
[Music]
these are civilian cars I imagine they
were hit really badly as far as I know
there was a family here trying to escape
not mines
did they run over mines no they were
just shot by the Russian bastards this
is the path we had to cover you can see
all the road and that cross over there
everything beyond that point were
Russian positions where we started our
advance
time to come
this is a canal it's filled up with
rubble as you can see the bridge was
blown up completely so we moved along
this canal there was a huge Crater from
the explosion in our way but we kept
moving forward if you look past that way
those five or seven pillars this is
where the pumping station is this is
where all the Russian bastards were why
did we move along the canal it was just
impossible to approach that place from
the field it was a Kill Zone fully
exposed to enemy fire canals were also
Under Fire but we made attempts to
advance there and to bring down their
surveillance cameras shoot down some of
the hostiles and so on about 300 meters
ahead there was that thing then our guys
arranged some sleeping places here and
later the guys also camped in this canal
this is our tank it's still here we
haven't taken it yet I reckon it's not
so easy to do that with such a road well
it's not bad now
we might return that way I showed you
how we were getting here in the summer
it was much drier and it was much easier
to get here but when it was raining it
was impossible to evacuate wounded or
bring anything no ammunition nothing if
not for the pickups the pickups provided
by volunteers we could do nothing only
some heavy army trucks could get there
but we only have a few of them and they
are quite noticeable targets everyone
tried to take the strong point which
seemed impossible you know it was it was
like Mecca
troops kept coming here for three or
four months but no one could capture it
and then there was this Tipping Point we
captured it and pushed forward forcing
the Russians to retreat we were
advancing from One Tree Line to another
one after the other we were also
learning you know we didn't fight in a
step before not me at least so we needed
to work out some scheme first we covered
the area with these types of Weaponry
then we use other types then we approach
from this side and then we advance from
the other there's a really great
Battalion Commander with the call sign
lunch name his name is Yan his
subordinates say that he's some kind of
a Maniac but he is one of those
commanders who fight really well they
are well-like commanders who do not
force people to move forward and yet
they lose the same number of soldiers at
their positions due to artillery fire
there are also commanders who push
forward fight their way through and of
course they also lose people but at the
same time they achieve the results so if
we take these two commanders the first
one is of a likable type but he stays
put and gets stuck in one place while
the other one is pushing forward all the
time and because of this he is not
popular I assume for the sake of our
country and its history we need more
commanders of the unpopular type he's a
bit crazy but I love him for that he's a
true professional and he moves forward
he is constantly working with his people
he devises some tactical schemes drills
them and so on so a good Commander from
the subordinates point of view is not
always the effective one a commander may
seem a despot to his subordinates but
again I know that those who have some
experience will respect him and those
who say keep their asses in the trans
and refuse to move those with low
discipline to them such Commander will
certainly be a tyrant a tyrant yes
that's a philosophical topic of the war
so how did you guys manage to take that
pumping station at the end a group
entered the perimeter and shot all the
hostiles down with assault rifles by the
way their bodies they were lying there
for a long time nobody was taking them
away we called them the guards of the
pumping station
I don't even know if this has been done
yet it could well be that no one has
taken them away
and as it happens no one gives a damn
about them and no one wants to touch
this rock you know what I'm saying we
took the bodies of our soldiers and that
was it an irrigation system
yep that's the one and it cost Millions
you can see that it's also damaged it's
destroyed but I believe that one day
it'll be repaired by the way what a
striking difference it is to see the
positions of our guys and the Russians
our positions they're clean and tidy the
guys collect all the garbage while those
Russian bastards are like some bums they
eat sleep and [__] all in the same place
mm-hmm
was this some sort of Russian command
post here
no this was a strong point they were
hiding here under the ground there are
lots of videos of how our guys throw
grenades from drones right into their
dugouts the work of the Drone operators
here was highly professional
they sometimes managed to throw several
grenades into the event
a lot of Russians were killed with the
DGI mavic 3 drones and grenades
so that a grenade would explode right
over it but we uncovered them over and
over again and they kept losing their
people
come on
take a souvenir keep it
you can see a lot of Russian military
uniform pieces here we needed to come in
here and kick them out and then enter
the pumping station and recapture it and
we had no idea of the Russian's actual
numbers and where they were walk on the
path only all right follow my steps
please were they applying some
electronic warfare why didn't you know
how many of them there were
well they had all sorts of things they
still have all sorts of things it's a
mistake to underestimate their army they
can detect the moving of the equipment
by sound they use some microphones
and they also saw us with their drones
they could see a lot by the way I think
that generator over there looks
functional
oh
send some people to check it out right
good eye well spotted
can you see how stripped this 4x4 is
step very carefully do not move around
your curiosity can kill you
I doubt you could film anything like
this
and who knows what's buried under all
this [__] they are here forever huh
there's still some of those Billboards
just you look at that Russia is here to
stay forever you see Russia is to stay
forever
so they had another way out here
can you imagine how heavily our
artillery peppered this area we beat the
hell out of this place because this was
their strong point
did they have solar panels yeah they
stripped the panels from the houses and
brought them here
did they try to plug them in somehow
yeah I assume so follow my steps
precisely
have you any idea how many of them fell
here
nobody counted them I wonder how a tally
of enemy deaths is made are those just
guesstimates
the figures reported by our military no
those are guesstimates every day there
are
uh don't bother trying to remove it the
mud will stick back on right away
the video footage was used taken from a
mavic drone for example they used to put
together those
what's it called the reports you can't
just announce that you killed 10
hostiles
also the counting is usually based on
the vehicle's capacity
for example we hit a tank so you know
that its crew consists of three people
God
yeah this is our tank
our guys died here
the Russian Artillery was blasting us
from over there and to this tree line
these trees survived so to say two
fighting waves the first one was an
artillery strike and the second was the
Russians won artillery had less power so
as we reached this place the trees were
still standing but not for long the
Russians knew these positions very well
right well they could see all this place
mind you they've got satellites drones
you name it if you stay behind that tree
line over there and also night they were
defending and we had to come close
enough to that tree line to be able to
kill them you can try to imagine what it
was like and again you don't know if
this field is mine but you need to cross
it to kick them out that's the
liberation of hersson we were talking
about and so it was with every tree line
every field you know when they say we
Advanced one kilometer that might sound
trivial they were captured some field
which you can't even see on the map and
do you know how many of those fields
there are you've traveled Lane haven't
you have you seen those numerous Fields
yes I have we captured such a small area
it might look insignificant on a global
scale and yet this could well become
that last drop in the bucket that would
help us take back
but then think about how many people's
lives we paid for this drop this field
here
all right
it's not the tank that matters but it's
the people inside it you see and from
the look of it they all died
[Music]
you need to understand that even if we
now sign a peace treaty or something
like that with Russia it'll only be
temporary and how temporary for a year
two years or five years it remains
unclear Russia will return again eat in
10 or in 20 years that's why we should
stay vigilant even in 20 years from now
we must do everything to make our army
professional our army should be young
because now many of the fighters are
people in their 40s their 50s and 60s
and actually there are some 50 year olds
who fight better than soldiers in their
20s they're experienced and they may not
value their own lives as much as they
value the lives of their subordinates
what will our complete Victory look like
for you will it be the disintegration of
Russia and what is the disintegration of
Russia actually mean their country will
collapse
no tensions there'll be fights quarrels
but then they'll unite again and come at
us this already happened in 1917.
remember Russia did collapse once they
killed the Tsar the Communists gained
power and then what what did those
Communists do they came to Ukraine again
so when their country disintegrates when
it collapses and falls into ruins there
will be a lot of poor and those poor
once again will look at their neighbor
who lives well they'll Envy this
neighbor who has a Cherry Orchard by the
house whose house is white and tidy and
once again until the man to come to this
neighbor's house to Rob him Alex's land
and uses resources they've had this
mindset for centuries and sadly we
didn't learn anything from this from our
own mistakes we don't do enough to
become so strong that they don't even
dare to glance over our fence because
they'll know we'll immediately punch
them right in the teeth and punch him so
hard at the land of somewhere in Siberia
do you understand everyone needs to work
hard to achieve that entrepreneurs
should work hard to develop economy
journalists should work hard to convey
this point of view to everyone and the
military should work hard everyone
around should work hard to unite the
nation and first of all you know
teachers should work to bring up the
children we can't change those people
who live here right now those who lived
in the Soviet Union those who want to
have the Soviet Union back even after
Russia has come at us even though they
know perfectly what life in the Soviet
Union was like they keep praising
Russians as a brotherly nation and what
do the Russians do first their army
entersson and immediately after that
their teachers come to the city that's
what we should take care of we need our
teachers to perform patriotic education
and not just for the mark in a school
diary we need to teach our children
between 10 and 15 years old how to use
weapons professionally they need to
study weapons Robotics and operating
drones
they need to learn how to be in the
military they should be ready when they
grow up and if there's no war fine great
they'll become entrepreneurs and do
business they'll be much stronger
they'll have proper self-esteem and
they'll know how to use weapons and many
other things
in my time I was attending all those
clubs of model making including aircraft
and vehicle models and and whatever and
as you see it proved useful to me can
you imagine now I make machines that can
plant or remove mines I make machines
that collect drones for example when a
mavic drone Falls there's no need for a
person across the field to pick it up my
machine can drive there and get it
that's the future of our army
nevertheless returning to my question
what would you consider our final
Victory
the unification of our country the final
Victory will be when we restore order in
our country that's our final Victory and
also when we kick them back to the
border and Beyond
what is Victory it's the collapse of
another country it's defeat I don't
think our army is going to enter Moscow
what might happen is some form of
collapse of their political talk or
maybe something else
I'm not an expert and I can't foresee
all these events our Victory as well as
my personal victory
will be even when some strong people
will come into power people who will
live with honor and who will follow the
conscience
foreign
[Music]
not to mention to kick the Russians out
from their positions which they had
gained back in the spring
need to move that is why so much time
passed between the officials first
announcements of their plans to liberate
the southern region and the actual
deoccupation of her song
[Music]
what great men and women serve here and
in the other regions too
yesterday we talked to one of the former
members of the special police force who
had returned the Ukrainian flag to the
house on Regional administration
building are you really from Ukraine I
said yes we are they asked Are You
Soldiers
we said okay we believe you go on then
and we hoisted the flag
today we interviewed other guys
and they're engaged in intelligence and
aerial reconnaissance
these people are all different but
they're all incredibly motivated to kick
the Russian bastards out of our
territories
thank you
[Music]
foreign